today's topic kim kardashian made some
comments and it got what went viral and
people felt some type of way my advice
for women in business is you just have
to do what you're actually passionate
about because if you don't have passion
in it it's not easy regardless of how it
looks i thought courtney was going to
say some [ __ ] like uh write the quote
tales of your successful sister uh
[ __ ] nba player and get a baby vibe
get it baby baby baby
no she's a millionaire she's a
millionaire they're on their way to
billions i like how all these sister act
like they did some [ __ ] when like no but
you just came out the right place
some of y'all did none of the work i
think people see things with instant
gratification because of social media
that they think it just comes easy to
people it doesn't especially if you want
something long-term i have the best
advice for women in business get your
[ __ ] ass up and work
it seems like nobody wants to work these
days you have to know you have to
surround yourself with people
that want to work have a good work
environment where everyone loves what
they do because you have one life no
toxic work environments
and show up and do the work if you're
the smartest person in that room you've
got to go to another room like you don't
i want to be around really successful
people because that's going to drive me
to be successful all these like [ __ ]
self-help quotes um okay so a lot of
people heard these comments they got
upset there was a whole bunch of people
online and felt some type of way about
her comments i'll just let you go ahead
preach what do you think okay first and
foremost i believe that she's right it's
not what she said
it's who said it okay and that's what
got people pissed off it's not so much
that she people yeah you have to work
it's a it's a it's it's a hard job i was
speaking to someone person was like i
think i want to do this youtube thing i
don't want to do this you know when this
influence everything else okay what do
you want to do well i don't know for
what you think what you want to talk
about you have to find your niche well i
don't know
the more i was speaking to the person
the more i realized okay
you just don't want to you just want the
famous intention you don't want to do
the work you want that [ __ ] to come easy
to you and that's it got some people i
was talking to another person telling me
that one of his partners was buying
views
buying views you just want what the it
looks like yeah there's some people that
really do not want to work for it they
really want the instant gratification
now the problem is this what she said
was not the problem it's who said it
and coming from king k you know i mean
yeah you had to do is what
be at the right place at the right time
you forget that as well that aspect
because there's people that are working
hard there are some people that do work
hard and they will never get to your
level some people
get a succession of good luck and work
and he still don't get it and you got
good luck and it happens so let's not
let's not forget the fact that look
and being there at the right time and
capitalizing on that also
isn't is the factor it's not just hard
work girl please you were already in the
position where you started your career
where you had the luck to be at the
position that you're at you had the dad
that you you had the dad that you had
that had a whole lot of money and you
were able to chill with paris hilton
that was not work that was your daddy
come on because you see everything on
social media and you think oh it's just
a lifestyle or oh it's like really quick
and easy and you can just post something
and it's not easy when you do product
shots when you do post things that are
work related posts it's still a job and
it's still really hard and success is
never easy every time i see it in like a
fancy photo i just imagine on the left
side pete davidson's feeling
i banged that
where are you at pete in your wife's bed
that's fine bro if you put in the work
you will see results it's that simple
okay it's not that simple
you know that last line just makes me
cringe so hard okay but we'll get to
that in a little bit let's let's just go
from the top so this is one of the
interesting things about
success in life is folks take their
trajectory and then they'll say
this is what it is and this is the truth
right
people will say i met my wife and she
was a virgin and we've been together 40
years that's the truth you need a virgin
way right they go well everybody is
going to think that their way of doing
things is the right way and it lacks a
lot of perspective because
if you aren't honest about all the
things that contribute to where you got
to where you are then you can't really
be honest about your trajectory when i
hear her talk about this stuff i find it
a little strange because like preach
said
it's not like you just did a rags to
riches story boo boo you come from one
of the most famous lawyer families in
the world ain't that the man who
defended oj yeah it was part of the team
you come from like living in beverly
hills to having connections like here's
one thing that folks don't admit when
you come out of university the most
important part is not even the degree
it's the connections that you make
right because from that you're able to
garner more opportunities so if your
parents are boosters at the university
you're far more likely to get in the
university and stay inside because they
donate so much money those kind of
connections help you out throughout life
when you want to apply for a job you
think your resume's the most important
thing of course not who you know at the
company is going to be the biggest
determining factor of whether or not you
get in or not i know people who are [ __ ]
for brains bad resume they know the
right people they can get into anywhere
that's a fact of life there's certain
things that you will never have access
to that kim has and so here's another
weird thing
making your first 100 000 is very
difficult making the next million is
easy why because a lot of wealth issues
are exponential once you make money
making more of it is super quick i'm not
saying it's gonna always gonna work out
but it's a lot easier can you attest to
that yes sir there's a certain way that
this society functions where it's meant
to keep certain people down and keep
certain people up okay
and knowing that when people say stuff
like well just work hard and you'll get
there that's such a [ __ ] [ __ ] lie
even in the arts it's such a lie i see
stand-up comedians who go to open mics
every week
and they're on and they write and they
write and they've been at it for 15 20
years and they still trash why they're
working harder than literally everybody
i know but if you know anything about
business it's not about working hard
it's about working smart you can save as
much money as you want if you know the
right investment strategies you're going
to make more than anybody who learns how
to save put their money in a savings
account the savings account got a 0.534
interest rate you you getting an extra
15 bucks a year okay yay person who has
a good investment strategy understands
crypto understands stocks who
understands dividends all this stuff
they're going to make way more money why
because they know how to use their money
intelligently it's not enough to just
work hard
here's another thing that i learned now
that i've made a bit of money the
knowledge you learn from others who
actually have had money is super
important but i didn't know that because
i was financially illiterate the only
lesson my mom gave me is save your money
which
already a great lesson and thankfully it
saved me a lot then i had to learn about
tax free savings account i had to learn
about dividends i had to learn about
incorporating i had to learn about the
tax brackets i had to learn about tax
brackets for corporations versus
individuals all these little money
things that make a huge difference not
only in making more money but
maintaining your wealth
but guess what most people don't grow up
in those environments they don't even
know this information exists
that's the thing out there
when your dad tells you yo listen i know
you don't know what you're doing but you
made a lot of money at 18. let me help
you out with your investment strategies
i know this [ __ ] i've been managing that
is big difference than an 18 year old
who grows up from rags to riches and
then is broke once three years after
he's out of the league why do you think
so many of these athletes lose all their
money because they don't know they have
nobody around them to coach them a lot
of vultures around them and their
parents and their family have never had
money so they just know how to spend it
we have to stop this whole binary right
everyone thinks that they've got their
red pill they've got their truth and
their truth is absolute hard work you're
gonna get there that's not true
you need a combination of different
things i remember back in the day they
used to say this don't sleep don't sleep
until you're successful so [ __ ]
are pulling all-nighters all the time
not really they're shortening your
lifespan reducing their work abilities
right some of the worst hard work advice
i've ever heard not even that not even
that
they're reducing their lifespan
and they're cutting themselves from
their families yes
i mean that's a personal thing but i'm
just talking about from a work state but
after that they realized that they don't
have the support system to even do the
work that they were able to do yeah
i mean yeah it's from the personal
standpoint but it does affect your work
work agreed so i agree so so when she
sits down she's talking about like yeah
just work hard and it's that easy it's
like that's such a tone-deaf thing to
say there's people who are working hard
at their jobs every single day and they
will never see me upward mobility either
because the financial strain and the
responsibilities findings that they have
with the multiple kids and all this
stuff is so big they don't have
yeah but she had 90s things that you
will never have access to yeah not knees
paycheck to paycheck
it's not the same thing so so the thing
is with rich people like that people
that are born rich and rich people like
that you know what i'm gonna include
myself people that make a little bit of
money not even rich rich there's people
that the minute you make a little bit of
money the minute you start to be a
little bit disconnected a little bit i
include myself in that
yup and i was having this conversation
with one of my friends and he was saying
that yeah i've been
i've been having monies for like the
past four years now that i'm like i'm
making money money and i'm a bit
disconnected and i was like you're right
you are i'm disconnected too
people are talking [ __ ] about the gas
prices and i was like stop talking about
the guy
oh yeah
yeah well it's not a problem for me but
it's there it's outrageous the cast
prices are outrageous out there it's
crazy when you have a family and [ __ ]
like that and people are thinking about
selling their cars just because they
can't because the gas payment is is
bigger than the insurance and the car
payment
yeah it is a real problem and that's a
problem and she's she hasn't been i
don't know if it's because i'm connected
to
and i'm always afraid that i'm going to
go back to
i always remind myself that i can always
go back to where i was that's why i'm
still on childboom.com every wednesday i
received some some job application i'm
like oh i don't want to go back to that
right
but she's never been in that position
right never had to be in that position
so
there's a disconnect there is a
disconnect
for the rest of the family too the
younger they are in that family the
bigger the disconnect because they
really never
they never had that kim k was talked
about when the other one was young young
so she's like oh yeah that's life so you
know
the jenner girl yeah her connections to
the kardashians helped her get the agent
get the photographers get her all that
you think a young inspiring model can do
what jenner did there's a reason why
family within wealth within a family
that's prominent keeps growing
exponentially they're using their
connections with each other you think
courtney would have been successful
without the sister of the dad come on
now the mom is getting my money too for
what just stop just stop it it's i
cringe
it's hard work yeah but you have you
were in a position a very particular
position that made you
practice whatever you had access on the
topic of working hard was working smart
how many of you guys have worked towards
a degree that you later found out was
useless
you worked hard but you got it all
and you ended up finding it was useless
right now you're crying yourself to
sleep looking at student debt or maybe
you cleared it like for what
you worked hard wasn't the smartest move
but you didn't know better maybe or
maybe you did i don't know people work
hard every day and then go into a
[ __ ] dead end
that happens but i'm working
you need to work out smart or else you
get injured
so that's why they're telling you to
study up on things make sure you know
how to do all this stuff it's all
important work out efficiently not not
stupidly that's one part also the whole
thing about make sure there's no toxic
work environments that's a privilege
pool
when you pour you take what you can get
and you learn to accept it you learn to
accept it you don't have the luxury of
doing this this is like that's
privileged talking non-toxic work
environment who chooses their
supervisors no i can't do that i can't
work there because i got mouth to feed i
gotta work there it's a [ __ ] job but
i gotta [ __ ] do it yeah yeah yeah
it's not
it's not the best
huh
but
imagine looking at [ __ ] soldiers uh
no toxic work environment yeah let me go
fire my sergeant you the [ __ ] are you
talking about
the [ __ ] are you talking about really
love what you do that's a luxury too
when you most americans most people in
north america i think it's like 68 right
now with paycheck to paycheck yeah who
has the uh [ __ ] luxury there's
actually of choosing to love what you do
or no toxic work environments you live
paycheck to paycheck i think it's like
40 of the people that make more than a
hundred thousand dollars a year are
living a major debate right because they
live in a city where you make that much
but you pay crazy amounts so i don't
know to me it's a bit tone-deaf and i
think also a lot of the self-help guru
[ __ ] you just realize that live is
just fluff pieces to tell you like oh
you can do it if you do this this is
it's a lot more complicated than that
okay it's a lot more complicated than
that and honestly here's something i had
to accept like with stand up for example
some dogs are just not gonna make it
they're not cut out for it they don't
have the self-awareness to realize like
how their jokes are being interpreted
how their jokes come across to people
what's wrong within their joke they just
don't have the brain for it
not everyone is meant to do everything
that's why i say you have to understand
what your skill sets are and what you
can develop and what you don't have all
right if you got a busted knee guess
what if your knee is always busted you
probably can't do basketball as
professional athlete
it sucks a lot of nba athletes have lost
their careers but that's another thing
where working hard is not enough
there are certain realities you have to
accept
it doesn't mean you can't transition
your efforts elsewhere and find where
your skill sets matter and they're well
valued but understand that and also
this is the last thing i think in kim
k's defense success can look like a lot
of different things
maybe it's just a living wage where
you're able to take care of your family
put some savings go on a trip or two a
year that could be success for a lot of
people right it doesn't have to look
like a billionaire success can vary from
person to person
so i think it's encouraging to know like
with a certain level of work ethic and
thinking intelligently you can't create
that environment for yourself in a
reasonable sense but like
i i'm confused sometimes because i feel
like everybody thinks they're gonna be a
millionaire or something like that and
it's like bruh it's not going to happen
i don't even think i would get to a
point where i'm even close to that kind
of money i don't even think that ever
happened i was going to be fine with
just like yo listen let me just make a
like teacher salary doing state of i
would have been happy we also have to
stop glamorizing this entrepreneur six
seven figure lifestyle because it's not
feasible for most people he wanted to
pay my bills yeah
ain't that true i just wanted to pay my
bills
neither of us thought we'd get here no
no
not with that i just did it because it
was fun there you go and the result was
fun the comments and [ __ ] like that but
you were stressed
how stressed were you about the money
you know i told you yeah
we had that whole conversation yeah
there's even points where you're like i
don't know i might have to do other [ __ ]
i'm like oh man you figure out what you
got to do so it's not easy and you
didn't have no kids you know what i'm
saying you had a you had you had a girl
that was supporting you financially yeah
not everybody has your circumstances and
if you were born if you let's say if you
were a single dad
[ __ ]
do i think we'd probably be doing this
today probably probably would but we
found a way like it would be right there
you can't bring your kid here okay well
you're gonna have to wait outside
you got to do what you got to do bro
but it's rough it is but anyways let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below anything you just want to add no
no all right then let us know what you
think